some tells me today's message is gonna
save you from driving yourself insane
and you'll know why here in a minute
last week I was at our annual conference
in Las Vegas we had 5,000 people there
that's two times bigger than any other
conference we've had in the past before
Kevin Hart performed he was hilarious
Nick vucic was there four and a half
million dollar budget and during one of
the sessions on backstage speaking to
two of our leaders and I told him I said
I don't know if we spend enough time
talking about this concept with our
folks and they said what is it I said
when a person that's new in sales and
new as an entrepreneur you know starts
doing their business they get
disappointed very quickly because they
don't realize you can do everything
right with a climb with an agent with an
employee with a salesperson you can do
everything right and they can still
change their minds why because people
often change your minds people are
emotional beings well pack what should I
put my focus into should I not trust
people I don't know if I'm saying that
this is what I'm saying to you I know I
can control my effort I can't control
everybody's effort I can't control my
attitude I can't control everybody's
attitude I can control me keeping my
ward I can't control everybody keeping
their word I can't control me not
changing my mind all the time I can't
control people changing their minds all
the time I can control how I'm gonna
behave on a daily basis I can do the
other side by the way systems are not
emotional you can control systems people
are emotional you can't control people
trust systems drive systems trust your
mission trust your vision trust your
crew say trust what your vision is
long-term on what you're gonna be able
to do at the beginning stages of you
being a salesperson or an entrepreneur
you can do that with people because
they're gonna often change your minds
now does this mean it's always gonna be
like that not at all why the longer
you're in business you eventually find a
group of people that buy into you you
eventually find a group of people that
understand how consistent you are you
eventually find a group of people that
want to be in business with you forever
you eventually find a group of people
that like your style you eventually find
a group of people that like your vision
your crusade your cause your mission and
your vision is so big that other
people's vision also fits into it but it
won't happen
right off the bat and so while you're
watching this video and you're asking
yourself oh my gosh you know IIIi if I
land this one client it's gonna make me
$300,000 gonna change my life
I can't wait to land this client I find
land that one sales guy he's the best in
the market I gotta get this guy what
happens if they change their minds
do you also change your mind what
happened if they say no do you also get
down on yourself and say oh my gosh I
don't have to business for me no don't
let other people's emotions and
decisions and constant changing their
minds dictate your mind you focus on
your vision your mission and long-term
things that you want to do with your
life and eventually you'll find enough
people that wanna run with you